cinquante six mille à l'essence est
actuellement en 2014 la fédération
française de boxe collé d'une des plus
grosses progressions de féminisation +10
9%
le faux drôle et le ronron 5% alors
pourquoi un tel succès réponse le rire
[Musique]
je pense que ça peut pas et renforcer le
les muscles tout ça donc oui ce qu'on va
être ma nation je pense que c'est un
milieu plutôt masculin et snecma attire
aussi pourquoi pas les filles
là c'était spécial problèmes de la femme
donc donc c'est tout ensemble c'est un
sport on pense pas spécialement à le
faire quand on est une fille nous penser
dit voilà on s'initie si ça nous plaît
on continue
[Musique]
alors allemande à la femme d'un boss
n'est pas parce nous sommes exactement
c'est aussi un sport de femmes et vont
vraiment toute leur place dans la
discipline et d'ailleurs on a
aujourd'hui tout tout type de pratiques
qui permettent aux femmes de s'adonner
au noble art mais c'est différent j'y
mais je ne sais pas tout à fait les
mêmes mouvements que cette année de boxe
c'est pas alors c'est les mêmes
techniques c'est les mêmes règles mais
c'est pas la même pratique
en fait les femmes vont chercher plus la
condition physique
le cardio le renforcement musculaire et
pour moins cher chez l'opposition elles
sont plus frileuses en général et donc
elles vont chercher à s'amuser et à
pratiquer différents vous avez dit qu'a
lieu j'imagine c'est un sport aussi qui
entraîne une maîtrise de son corps aussi
une bonne connaissance
oui c'est un sport qui est très complet
en fait on utilise les membres
inférieurs pour les déplacements on a
besoin d'explosivité et on utilise les
membres supérieurs pour l'attaqué la
défense est donc là on a besoin
également de
la qualité physique et donc ça fait un
sport très très complète essayé bien sûr
un grand plaisir
allez on y va
[Musique]
un entraînement de boxe durent en
général deux heures il existe différents
styles à boucan